the president met with a bipartisan
group of lawmakers at the White House
seeking solutions to what some consider
an epidemic of gun violence in schools
and public places a lively discussion in
the Cabinet Room again carried live on
TV networks both parties we welcome back
our chief White House correspondent John
Roberts this was his original story
today as often he gets put on other
stories as they break late in the day
good evening again John it happens from
time to time Brett this was the file of
four listening sessions that the
president was holding in the wake of the
shooting at the Marjory Stoneman Douglas
High School in parkland Florida a
spirited session with both Republicans
and Democrats airing their ideas and the
president tomorrow was set to lay out
his administration's proposals for
improving school safety
it was another TV moment today the White
House canceling the daily briefing
turning the cameras on president Trump's
congressional meeting on school
shootings and gun safety we have to act
we can't wait and play games and nothing
gets done as the president was convening
his meeting word spread that the Dick's
Sporting Goods chain where the parklands
shooter once bought a shotgun would stop
selling assault rifles the systems that
are in place across the board just
aren't effective enough to keep us from
selling someone a gun like that and so
we've decided that we're not gonna sell
the assault rifles and tomorrow the
White House will unveil a package of
policy proposals to improve gun safety
and stop school shootings the president
will reiterate his support for the stop
school violence act and the corn and
Murphy bill to improve background checks
none of us want to look these families
in the face
wake of another mass shooting and say we
failed to do everything within our power
to stop mr. president is gonna have to
be you that brings the Republicans to
the table on this because right now with
the gun lobby would stop it in his
tracks President Trump will also asked
Congress to raise the minimum age to buy
a rifle from 18 to 21 you are going to
decide the people in this room pretty
much you're going to decide but I would
get very serious doctor I can say that
the NR as opposed to it the president
chided some of his Republican colleagues
including Pennsylvania Senator Pat
Toomey for being afraid of the NRA
tomorrow the president will also
announce a series of administrative
actions to expand a DHS test program to
stop school violence fixed the FBI
tipster program encouraged States to
adopt extreme risk protection orders so
that weapons could be taken away from
people who threatened to harm themselves
or others and encourage arming school
faculty and staff through federal grants
or federal training the president also
said he'll eliminate so-called bump
stocks with a stroke of his executive
pen but he warned Majority Whip Steve
Scalise did not attach a concealed carry
reciprocity measure to any legislation
on background checks if you're gonna put
concealed carry between states into this
bill we're talking about a whole new
ballgame you know president Trump also
had the Russia investigation on his mind
today again taking his Attorney General
out to the woodshed after Jeff sessions
said he would ask the DOJ x' inspector
general to look into the FISA abuses
alleged in the Republican House
Intelligence Committee memo in a tweet
the president writing why is AG Jeff
Sessions asking the Inspector General to
investigate potentially massive FISA
abuse will take forever has no
prosecutorial power and already late
with reports on Comey etc isn't the IG
and Obama guy why not use Justice
Department lawyers disgraceful the
president got some backup from the
Reverend Jerry Falwell Jr who tweeted
that sessions could be just a coward
sessions who has often stayed silent
under scorching criticism from his boss
decided this one too
and a response in a statement saying we
have initiated the appropriate process
that will ensure complaints against this
department will be fully and fairly
acted upon if necessary as long as I am
the Attorney General I will continue to
discharge my duties with integrity and
honor sessions found support from
Oversight Committee chairman trey Gowdy
whose findings the Inspector General
will investigate Gowdy saying Michael
Horowitz quote has been fair fact
centric and appropriately confidential
with his work I have complete confidence
in him just yesterday the press
secretary Sarah Huckabee Sanders seemed
to indicate that the president was
pleased about the fact that sessions had
announced that he was going to
investigate possible FISA abuses clearly
this was not the type of investigation
that the president was looking for and
has again raised questions as to how
much longer sessions will take this very
public criticism from the president
before he decides he too will leave the
White House Brett I think that's all we
have for you today John thank you see
you tomorrow